After more than four decades as a manufacturing and financial powerhouse,...
...Japan's decline confirms China's emergence as an economic superpower.
Although analysts said it was only a matter of time...
...before China took the number two spot from Japan,...
...the speed of the transition surprised many in Tokyo.
I knew the time would come one day, but I did not think it would be this soon.
Analysts say China's growth played the key role in pulling the world out of a global recession.
Already this year, China has become the biggest market for automobiles...
...and, according to another study,...
...the world's largest consumer of energy.
Lewis Cowles is senior economist at the China office of the World Bank.
China's growth is having increasingly an impact on many other regions of the world.
In part, that is via the things that China buys...
...commodities, technology, capital goods from Germany,...
...but more commodities from countries like Australia and Brazil, many other emerging markets.
Beijing residents expected this day would come,...
...but Victor Gao, director of China's National Association of International Studies,...
...warns against reading too much into the latest figures.
First of all, GDP is only one way to look at the economy...
...and there is also a very important criteria that is the quality of the GDP.
For example, when China surpasses Japan as an economy,...
...when we look at the Japanese economy,...
...I would personally say we still have a lot to learn from the Japanese.